bonjour à tous je vous retrouve
aujourd'hui pour un nouvel épisode de
sociologique et cette fois ci je suis
dans l'actualité parce que au moment où
nous découvrons sur nos écrans la
huitième et dernière saison de game of
thrones j'en profite pour faire un petit
point sur ce que l'analyse des réseaux
sociaux peuvent nous apprendre de la
série et de fait je pense que game of
thrones c'est une des séries sur lequel
le plus de chercheurs ils sont allés de
leur petite analyse diverses et variées
sûrement pour casser avec la monotonie
de leur métier d'ingénieur statisticiens
sans aucun a priori sur les ingénieurs
statisticiens heureusement que vous êtes
là les gars et les meufs
c'est ainsi qu'on a pu lire dans la
revue in jury epidemiology une étude
tout à fait sérieuse important sur 330
personnages de la série de la saison 1 à
visant à évaluer la durée de vie moyenne
d'un personnage dans game of thrones
les chercheurs en ont conclu que le
temps de survie médian des personnages
et de 28 heures et 48 minutes sur une
durée totale de la série de pour
l'instant environ 67 eur ce qui signifie
qu'un nouvel arrivant dans la série a
une chance de 14% de se faire tuer dans
l'heure qui suit son apparition et le
lien vers l'étude et dans la description
pour ceux qui veulent aller plus loin il
ya aussi des démographes français qui se
sont penchés sur la série et qui ont
essayé de prévoir quels sont les
personnages qui ont le plus de chances
de mourir dans la saison 8 en se basant
sur les informations contenues dans les
saisons 1 à 7
on a donc vu naître deux magnifiques
infographie qui nous indique le type
d'armes utilisé le nombre de morts par
saison et leur estimation de la chance
qu'ont les différents personnages de
mourir
encore une fois les liens sont dans la
description et je vous encourage
vraiment à aller le voir leur site est
vraiment super bien fait et très
pédagogique
mais si la mort est évidemment un des
événements sans trop de game of thrones
on va se poser aujourd'hui une toute
autre question une des raisons qui fait
que game of thrones est un terrain
d'investigation aussi intéressant pour
ses recherches ça tient principalement à
la richesse et la complexité de son
univers est aussi principalement à son
nombre très élevé de personnages qui
rend parfois difficile de s'y retrouver
même quand on suit la série depuis le
début pourquoi les vous vers le reste je
sais pas qui c'est vrai pardonnez moi
non mais machin là le mec que je veux
aller chercher là son nom ça me dit
quelque chose mais je vois pas quelle
tête et là il s'agit de l'oncle de
catelyn stark et des de marteler je sais
pas qui fait non plus
implore de mesurer l'importance de la
tâche qui vous encombre je vous rappelle
que laure davos a mobilisé ses troupes
pour de soutenir ces lequel il est blanc
avec une barbe assez de blancs avec une
barbe d'accord non mais on est tous
blancs avec une barbe venues d'arrivée
vous qua non et en plus je suis là
depuis le début mais dès que je retenais
le nombre en gaélique revenant que je
laissais tomber quoi et de fait c'est un
petit peu le problème quand on fait une
étude sur la durée de vie moyenne d'un
personnage parce que en fait il n'ya pas
de personnages moyens et même s'il
georges martin a rendu très clair l'idée
selon laquelle il n'y a pas de
personnage principal est que personne
absolument personne n'est à l'abri de la
mort dans des hedge funds
oui moi aussi je pleure encore un petit
peu la nuit en pensant aux red wings ce
n'est pas pour autant qu'on peut mettre
tous les personnages sur un pied
d'égalité
et du coup la question à laquelle on va
essayer de répondre aujourd'hui c'est
tout simplement
c'est qui le personnage principal dans
game of thrones et pour ça on va
s'appuyer sur l'analyse des réseaux
sociaux
alors une petite parenthèse avant de
commencer quand je parle des réseaux
sociaux je suis pas en train de dire que
les personnages de game of thrones
passent leur temps sur facebook à
s'envoyer des scènes filles en cause
[Musique]
mais parce que c'est vrai qu'aujourd'hui
quand on parle de réseaux sociaux on a
tout de suite tendance à penser réseaux
sociaux numériques
mais de fait le réseau social d'un
individu si qu'une représentation de
l'ensemble de ses relations et il n'y a
pas besoin d'avoir internet pour avoir
réseau social alors de fait à l'analyse
en termes de réseaux sociaux est bien
plus ancienne qu'internet elle est
particulièrement utile quand on étudie
le système dynamique des relations
sociales en particulier quand il ya un
très grand nombre d'individus comme
c'est typiquement le cas dans game of
thrones
alors du coup pour essayer d'évaluer le
degré d'importance d'un individu il
s'agira pas seulement d'étudier sa
position formelle au sein des relations
sociales
parce que même endroit ça peut déchoir
mais plutôt quelle est leur position
informel dans l'ensemble des relations
formé par le subtil jeu des trônes
auquel les personnages sont obligés de
se plier s'ils veulent survivre money
play the game of thrones jean louis
darré
tableaux de maîtres ou quoi et c'est
justement se contenter d'étudier deux
chercheurs à l'université de mal à
caster dans le minnesota le
mathématicien andrew djb fridge et son
étudiant jitian qui se sont appuyés sur
le troisième livre de la saga pour
reconstituer les réseaux sociaux de
chacun des personnages du livre et
surtout d'évaluer leur degré de
centralité ce qui va être le maître mot
de cette étude un générique un petit peu
différent de mon générique habituel
aujourd'hui mais j'ai trouvé cette
création de la chaîne ou de suite et ça
colle est beaucoup trop à mon sujet pour
que je n'utilise pas comme générique
[Musique]
je voulais dire les réseaux sociaux
c'est pas nouveau il sont pas nés avec
internet et ils ne font que représenter
l'ensemble des relations entre un
individu et les personnes ou les groupes
de personnes avec lesquelles il
interagit alors je dis avec des
personnes mais pas forcément en fait un
réseau social ça peut représenter
l'ensemble des relations
évidemment entre des personnes mais
aussi entre des entités comme des
entreprises mais aussi entre des vaches
des protéines des neurones ou même des
publications scientifiques
si c'est ça qu'on est en train d'étudier
l'analyse en fait en termes de réseaux
sociaux elle a été très à la mode
principalement partir des années 90 mais
elle est toujours beaucoup à la main
d'aujourd'hui et elle est utilisée dans
un très grand nombre de disciplines
j'ai commencé par vous donner quelques
exemples pour qu'on voit mieux de quoi
on est en train de parler ici par
exemple on a le travail d'un
mathématicien qui représente le réseau
d'interactions physique entre des
protéines
donc chaque petit point là c'est une
protéine et lait trait qui les relient
basse et les formes d'interactions
physique une forme de réseau à laquelle
on est beaucoup plus habitués c'est le
réseau géographique le plan du métro ne
fait que nous montrer les différents
liens qui existent entre les différentes
stations et on voit qu'il existe des
stations très central auquel on pourra
accéder par de nombreux moyens et
d'autres plus excentrés qui nécessitent
non printemps en enchaînements précis de
relations en sociologie des sciences des
chercheurs ont également reproduit des
réseaux de citations entre différents
articles de chimie qui sont rasées selon
leurs co apparition dans la liste de
référence à la fin d'un article
on voit donc en un coup d'oeil que
certains articles sont très centraux et
son site et de nombreuses fois et on
peut se demander mais qu'est ce qu'il
fait là ce petit chéri tout excentré qui
s'est fait citer qu'une seule fois et
avec aucun des autres en sociologie
économique
on a vu aussi des travaux qui montre les
liens familiaux qui existe entre les
dirigeants des entreprises du cac 40
et ça permet donc de mettre en évidence
que des liens entre certaines
entreprises ne sont pas uniquement liées
à leurs activités économiques et qu'ils
sont aussi redoublé par des liens de
sang l'anthropologie s'intéresse
également aux réseaux en particulier les
réseaux de migrants comme le montre cet
exemple qui représentent les réseaux des
argentins qui ont immigré en catalogne
les historiens se sont eux aussi frotté
à l'analyse de réseaux comme le montre
cet exemple qui reconstitue le réseau
d'un père de l'abbaye de cluny
à partir de son apparition dans les
chartes et on voit comment son réseau
passe des milieux aristocratiques de sa
famille vers des milieux religieux pour
revenir vers le milieu de la cour et des
princes
bref vous avez compris des réseaux
sociaux y en a partout et ça peut nous
permettre de montrer un cheat l'hôte de
trucs qu'on verrait pas forcément si on
étudiait simplement les individus isolés
où les structures dans lesquelles ils
sont imbriqués en sociologie
l'analyse en termes de réseaux sociaux
c'est typiquement ce qui vient
s'imbriquer entre la vision holiste de
la société et l'individualisme
méthodologique
on en avait déjà un petit peu parlé avec
durkheim d'un côté et webber de l'autre
justement ça se situe à une échelle
intermédiaires etc l'échelle qu'on
appelle méo sociologique les revenants
sont un peu à la sociologie justement on
va maintenant essayer de comprendre
comment ça se construit un réseau social
en sociologie déjà ce qu'il faut voir
c'est qu'il existe plusieurs types de
réseaux et plusieurs façons d'utiliser
cet outil en sociologie
donc je vais procéder par étapes en
allant du plus petit et du plus intuitif
aux plus larges et aux plus complexes
on va commencer par parler des réseaux
personnels qui reconstitue les
sociabilités d'un seul individu
on va ensuite étudié ce qu'on appelle
les réseaux complet qui étudie
l'ensemble des relations au sein d'un
espace clair et préalablement définis on
va ensuite éloigné encore la focale pour
étudier ce qu'on appelle les réseaux
petit monde et enfin on va voir comment
ces réseaux peuvent être utilisés comme
des ressources par les individus je
commence par le plus simple les réseaux
personnels pour reconstruire le réseau
social de quelqu'un le sociologue il
demande à son enquête et de faire la
liste de tous les individus avec
lesquels il interagit l'idée c'est de
voir que les individus ne sont pas des
êtres isolé qui prennent leurs décisions
uniquement en fonction de leur
nationalité ou de leurs déterminants
sociaux mais que les villes sont reliées
et que ces différentes interactions
influence les choix des individus
alors on va construire le réseau
personnel de jacky on va dire qu'il
interagit avec ses parents avec sa grand
mère avec son frère sa soeur sa copine
ses amis d'enfance les copains de son
équipe de quidditch et son professeur de
triangle bon je simplifie un en général
les réseaux personnels sont beaucoup
plus vastes et après ça on va lui
demander quels sont les liens entre ces
différentes personnes donc on peut
imaginer que les personnes de sa famille
se connaissent de même pour ses amis
d'enfance qui sont même souvent invitée
à la maison
donc il connaît sa famille
pareil pour sa copine qui le lâche
rarement d'une semelle et on peut
supposer que tous les copains de son
équipe de quidditch se connaissent entre
eux et que eux n'ont peut-être pas
forcément de lien avec les autres à part
sa copine parce qu'elle aime bien aller
assister à leur entraînement alors vous
remarqué assez vite qu'il commence à y
avoir des traits dans tous les sens et
du coup ce qu'on fait le plus souvent
c'est qu'on supprime tout simplement ego
un la personne dont on fait le réseau
parce que après tout c'est inutile de le
mettre il a forcément un lien avec tout
le monde puisque c'est son réseau qu'on
est en train de faire ce réseau nous
permet donc de voir trois groupes assez
différent on appelle ça des clics avec
les amis proches la famille d'un côté et
les copains de l'autre avec la copine
qui fait le lien entre plusieurs parties
du réseau et le professeur de triangle
oui bah il est tout seul dans son coin
je précise aussi que là je me suis
contenté de représenter les liens par un
simple trait mais on peut aussi apporter
de la complexité en spécifiant le type
de lien est ce qu'ils sont à sens unique
est ce qu'ils sont réciproques sont ils
constitués d'une dimension affective au
contraire d'une relation hostilités
autant d'éléments qu'on peut décider
d'ajouter ou non et qui dépendent en
fait de notre question de recherche les
limites de ce type de construction de
réseaux c'est que le sociologue repose
uniquement sur la parole de l'enquêté
donc ici de jacky 1 on est donc limité
par ses connaissances par exemple jacky
ne s'est peut-être pas qu'il existe un
lien entre sa famille et son club de
quidditch parce que sa petite soeur a
pris pour habitude d'aller faire des
bisous avec drago malefoy tous les
mercredis soirs quand ils vont boire des
bières on cache est en haut de la tour
d'astronomie et du coup on n'a aucune
idée de si la réaction de jacky face à
cette information serait plutôt ou si sa
réaction serait plutôt passe
tu es
malgré ses limites ce type d'étude donne
quand même un certain nombre
d'informations assez intéressant sur les
relations d'une personne voilà l'exemple
d'un véritable réseau social
personnelles tirées d'une étude
sociologique
quand on observe ce réseau on peut
déduire simplement en observant sa
structure un certain nombre de choses
on peut voir ici une grosse clic
c'est-à-dire un réseau très dense où
tout le monde connaît tout le monde
typiquement c'est très rare de perdre de
vue des relations dans ce type
d'organisation parce que même si vous
oubliez d'appeler par exemple nicole il
ya de fortes chances qu'elle soit quand
même invité au soir et parce que le
groupe de copains va l'inviter donner
les nouvelles etc
donc on reste plus en relation quand on
est inséré dans une clique
mais en même temps les liens isolés sont
souvent les survivants de contexte qui
ont disparu par exemple ce copain de
lycée que tu continues à voir
régulièrement alors même que le réseau
dense de relation que vous aviez à
l'époque n'existe plus ça veut dire
qu'on à autonomiser la relation est qu
on la découpe les de son contexte
par exemple ici le lycée et ça c'est
aussi un indice que le lien est assez
fort donc ce qu'il faut voir c'est que
tous les liens ne se valent pas et la
structure du réseau donne des
informations sur la nature de ses liens
par exemple on peut supposer que la
personne dont on a fait les réseaux ne
peut en fait pas blairer nicole mais
qu'elle est bien obligé de garder
contact avec elle parce que elle est
insérée dans une clique
par contre ce qui est particulièrement
remarquable dans ce réseau c'est la
centralité de stéphane hains
il est en lien avec absolument tout le
monde et pour mieux comprendre son rôle
le mieux c'est d'ajouter une dimension à
l'analyse et de ne pas se contenter
uniquement de la structure du réseau
mais aussi de qualifier les différents
types d'interactions on voit que si on
colore ses liens en fonction de leurs
différents rôles
on comprend mieux ce réseau donc on a
ici on jeunes les liens familiaux envers
la belle-famille et en bleu les copains
et les amis et on comprend vite que
stéphane rose représente bien évidemment
le conjoint qui fait le lien entre les
différents groupes
ça nous permet également de mettre
l'accent sur le statut tout particulier
qu'à la relation de couple dans nos
sociétés qui devient une espèce de super
lien qui vient se superposer à toutes
les relations sociales de l'individu
message est déjà prévu d'en reparler
dans un autre épisode donc je vais pas
m'appesantir là dessus alors le deuxième
type de réseau ans et celui qui va le
plus nous intéresser ici c'est ce qu'on
appelle les réseaux complet alors quand
je parle de réseau complet
veut pas dire qu'il est plus dense ou
plus détaillée que le réseau personnel
en fait ce qui va changer ça va être la
façon de construire ce réseau au lieu de
prendre comme point de départ un
individu on va choisir plutôt d'étudier
une structure bien définie de préférence
fermé et clairement délimitées et on
étudie l'ensemble des relations qu'on
voit émerger au sein de cette structure
est typiquement c'est plutôt ce genre d'
analyse qu'on va utiliser pour étudier
la structure des relations de pouvoir au
sein de westeros tout estero ça ferait
un cadre un peu large mais en fait notre
cadre d' analyse ce sera plutôt
l'ensemble des personnages qui jouent au
jeu des trônes ce genre d' analyse voit
son origine dans les années 30
à travers le travail de jacob moreno qui
fait la toute première analyse qu'il
appelait sociométrie qu'en 1934 où il
retraçait tous les liens existant au
sein d'une prison pour jeunes filles
délinquante dans deux bâtiments
distincts on est donc bien dans une
analyse de réseaux complet parce qu'on a
un cadre défini et en retrace l'ensemble
des interactions à l'intérieur de ce
cadre
cela permet donc de mieux comprendre
comment peuvent circuler les
informations les rumeurs et
éventuellement les relations de pouvoir
et de fait ce type d'analysé
particulièrement intéressant pour
étudier les relations de pouvoir selon
ici deux critères principaux tout
d'abord la centralité des individus les
personnes qui sont au centre d'un grand
nombre d'interactions en plus de chances
d'avoir une position dominante au sein
du réseau et on peut mettre l'accent en
particulier sur les individus qui joue
le rôle de lien entre plusieurs réseaux
de relation ici on peut voir que ces
quatre personnes ont une place très
particulière au sein de cette structure
car ce sont elles qui permettent de
faire le pont entre les deux réseaux en
sociologie on appelle ça des trous
structuraux et de fait les personnes qui
occupe la position de trous structurale
sont particulièrement importante parce
que de leurs comportements peuvent
dépendre la circulation de certaines
ressources entre différentes parties du
réseau
ce type d'analysé a connu beaucoup de
succès en sociologie des organisations
en particulier l'un des chercheurs
spécialistes de la question aujourd'hui
c'est emmanuel lazer gars qui
travaillent au cso le centre de
sociologie des organisations et qui
s'intéresse au réseau complet mais il va
apporter une dimension à l'analyse en
différenciant les réseaux sociaux en
fonction de la taille des structures
dans lesquelles ils s'intègrent pour
dire cela il utilise ainsi la métaphore
de la mare et des poissons dans son
article de 2007 publiés avec marie
thérèse journalisme mounier
et raphaël stoffer qui s'intitule des
poissons et des mares l'analyse de
réseaux multi niveaux dans cet article
il se sont intéressés au réseau
relationnel des chercheurs en
cancérologie en essayant d'étudier da
qui sont les chercheurs qu'on consulte
le plus qui ont le plus de notoriété et
du coup le plus de pouvoir au sein du
champ ce qui est pas vraiment surprenant
c'est que dans ce réseau les personnes
pour le plus de pouvoir c'est non
seulement des gros poissons c'est à dire
des gens influents reconnu qu'ils ont
beaucoup publié mais c'est aussi des
gens qui évoluent dans des grosses
marges c'est-à-dire dans des gros
laboratoires qui ont beaucoup de
ressources qui prennent beaucoup de
doctorants qui placent leurs doctorants
dans les autres laboratoires etc
et c'est ce qui fait la centralité d'un
individu s'est pas uniquement une
affaire personnelle
mais c'est aussi une affaire de réseau
institutionnel et inter
organisationnelles ainsi au terme de
leurs études ils ont réussi à retracer
quatre réseaux distants les gros
poissons dans les grosses marc les gros
poissons dans les petites mares les
petits poissons dans les grosses marc et
les petits poissons dans les petites
mares alors évidemment les grands
gagnants en termes d'influencé les gros
poissons dans les grosses marre on voit
qu'ils ont un gros réseau extrêmement
dense en terme de relation mais la
question qui reste c est ce qu il vaut
mieux être un petit poisson dans une
grosse mare ou un gros poisson dans une
petite mare je vais laisser emmanuel de
la vega répondre lui-même d'après un
extrait que j'ai trouvé de l'une de ses
conférences
alors napoléon disait
pour réussir en politique il valait
mieux être premier dans son village
corse que dernier appareil donc un gros
poisson pension fatigue m'a plutôt qu'un
petit poisson dans une grosse barre et
dans le domaine de la science celle
inverse ce que nous on a trouvé c'est
que pour rattraper les goûts alors il
n'y a pas dit a pas photo les gros
poissons dans les grosses marron les
performances est plus élevé et pour
rattraper les gros poissons dans les
grossman
il y avait que les petits poissons dans
les petites dans les grosses marques qui
pouvait me rattraper les gros poissons
dans les petites mares et le petit pois
dans les rythmes à le rattraper
en fait orelsan il avait compris avant
tout le monde l'analyse multi niveau des
réseaux épistémique de cancérologie
française bien joué si tu pèses à petite
échelle et que tu te raconte ira nulle
part ce sera trop tard quand tu droit
des folies le prince des souris
toujours plus fort c'est ça la morale de
l'histoire
maintenant qu'on a parlé des réseaux
personnels et des réseaux complet on va
parler de ce qu'on appelle les grands
réseaux ou les réseaux petit monde et
donc vous avez peut-être déjà entendu
parler avec la théorie des six degrés de
séparation
alors cette analyse est très connu et
vous en avez peut-être déjà entendu
parler mais je reviens quand même
brièvement dessus
la théorie des six degrés de séparation
stipule que si vous avez vous même
quarante quatre amis qui ont chacun 44 à
1000 différents qui ne sont pas aussi
vos amis et que chacun d'entre eux ont
également 44 amis qui ont chacun
quarante quatre amis qui ont encore
quarante quatre amis qui en auront de
même 44 chacun est bien dans cette
situation si on calcule le nombre de
personnes avec lesquelles on peut être
en contact avec michel de seulement six
individus on sera en contact avec 7,26
milliards d'individus
ce qui est à peu près l'équivalent de la
totalité de la population mondiale
alors c'est un raisonnement qui est pour
le moment uniquement mathématiques mais
qui ne date pas d'hier l'écrivain
hongrois frigyes karinthy écrivait déjà
une nouvelle en 1929 dans laquelle un
des personnages des 6 un autre
personnage de trouver ne serait-ce
qu'une seule personne sur la planète à
laquelle ils ne pourraient pas se
connecter en moins de six connexion mais
il faudra plusieurs années avant que la
science tente de valider cette intuition
et c'est notamment ce que va essayer de
faire en 1967 le psychosociologue
stanley milgram à travers son expérience
du petit monde au passage oui c'est bien
le même me g qui a fait l'expérience sur
la soumission à l'autorité mais j'ai pas
prévu d'en parler parce qu'il ya au
moins 40 de vidéos quand on parle déjà
sur youtube et qui le font bien mieux
que je ne saurais le faire lorsque la
ferme il g c'est qu'ils en bois 60
lettres à des recrues de la ville
d'omaha dans le nebraska et leur demande
de faire suivre cette lettre à un avant
de change qui vit dans la ville de
sharon dans le massachusetts
mais le fait est que les recrues ne
devait pas envoyer ces lettres par la
poste
non ils devaient les données de main en
main à une connaissance qu'il pensait
capable d'atteindre l'objectif
or bien que 50 personnes se soient
prêtés à l'expérimentation seulement
trois lettres sont arrivées à
destination
le célèbre article de milgram montre en
effet qu'une des lettres mis que quatre
jours à arriver en négligeant un petit
peu de préciser que seulement 5% des
lettres était arrivé à leurs objectifs
mais ce qui est intéressant de remarquer
c'est que pour les lettres qui sont
effectivement arrivées elles ont
nécessité en moyenne 5
deux intermédiaires pour arriver à
destination ce qui semblerait donc
confirmer la théorie des six degrés de
séparation alors l'une des difficultés
principales de cette expérience c'est
qu'on suppose que les personnes dans la
chaîne sont compétentes pour savoir
quels sont les liens à activer pour
relier les deux personnes qui servent de
terminaux en fait si ça se trouve il y
avait bien pour chacun des sujets un
moyen d'arriver en six étapes d'une
personne à l'autre
juste que les personnes ne savaient pas
qui dans leurs contacts étaient les
meilleures personnes à mobiliser pour
amener le paquet d'un bout à l'autre
alors de fait il référence de milgram
n'a pas été ultra probante à l'échelle
du globe
en fait ce qu'elle a pu montrer par la
suite c'est qu'il existe des petits
monde c'est à dire des réseaux imbriqué
dans lesquelles n'importe quelle
personne inclus dans ce réseau peut
atteindre n'importe quel autre en en
très petit nombre d'étapes
il est par exemple une étude qui
s'appelle six degrees of kevin bacon qui
a pu montrer que l'on peut relier
facilement n'importe quel acteur
hollywoodien à kevin bacon
cela a montré que le degré de séparation
entre tous les acteurs hollywoodiens est
extrêmement faible
ça c'est principalement dû au fait qu'il
ya un grand nombre d'acteurs qui joue le
rôle de second rôle dans beaucoup de
films et qui du coup peuvent faire le
rôle de lien entre les différentes
personnes ce qui fait que le réseau des
acteurs hollywoodiens constitue en fait
un petit monde et des petits monde de
plus en plus grands ont été rendues
possibles avec les réseaux sociaux
numériques en 2011 l'université de milan
a créé un algorithme capable de calculer
le degré de distance moyenne entre deux
personnes inscrites sur le réseau social
facebook
à l'époque il y avait déjà 720 millions
d'utilisateurs et l'étude a montré qu'il
faut en moyenne 4 74 personnes pour
relier n'importe quel couple d'individus
inscrits sur la plateforme
et si on resserre ça à l'échelle de la
france il ne faut plus que trois étapes
pour relier n'importe quel français
inscrits sur facebook alors l'intérêt de
ces analyses de type petit monde s'est
en fait d'essayer de mieux comprendre
comment se détermine l'accès à certaines
ressources pour les individus grâce à
leur réseau social
dans l'expérience de milgram c'était
simplement comment réussir à faire
passer une lettre mais ça peut aussi
être comment réussir à trouver une
audition où un rôle dans le petit monde
des acteurs hollywoodiens et ça peut
aussi être comment réussir à trouver un
emploi et à plusieurs recherches qui ont
été faites pour essayer de déterminer
comment se déroule la circulation de ce
type d'information dans les réseaux
sociaux et j'en parlerai notamment dans
un autre épisode pour aller vite ce type
d'études pointe notamment l'importance
de ce qu'on a
des trous structuraux c'est à dire les
personnes qui sont capables de jouer le
rôle de pont entre deux réseaux et donc
de faire mieux circuler l'information
entre des réseaux qui ne se connaissent
pas et donc de réduire ainsi
considérablement le nombre
d'intermédiaires
on arrive à notre quatrième partie où on
va étudier un peu l'intérêt de l'analyse
de réseaux en sociologie et qui tourne
souvent autour des questions d'accès aux
ressources pour les individus l'intérêt
des réseaux sociaux ainsi qu'ils font
apparaître les sociabilités les
relations entre les individus comme je
voulais déjà dit en sociologie on ne
peut souvent deux échelles d'analysé
l'analyse structurale aux listes d'un
côté on va étudier les structures
sociales qui sont coercitives et qui
détermine l'individu et de l'autre côté
l'individualisme méthodologique et qui
s'intéresse plutôt à l'individu seul et
comment ils opèrent ces choix et bien le
réseau c'est justement l'analyse mais au
sociologique qui était si cher notamment
à norbert elias et qui permet de
réinsérer l'individu dans une dynamique
un peu plus complexe que de le décrire
seulement en fonction de ces variables
sociodémographiques comme l'âge le sexe
la classe sociale ou le lieu
d'habitation
et le fait est que c'est bien souvent
insuffisant de s'intéresser uniquement
en position il est rare chic des
individus pour bien comprendre comment
se déroule l'organisation sociale parce
que de fait vous pouvez être un roi
placé tout en haut de l'échelle sociale
mais si vous restez dans votre tour
d'ivoire entre jamais en relation avec
les autres votre pouvoir réel il sera en
fait assez limité alors bien sûr dans la
réalité tout cela est lié à la nature
des réseaux dans lesquelles les
individus sont impliqués dépendent
grandement de leur position sociale et
de fait il ya des individus très
intégrée par exemple des cadres qui vont
cumuler un très grand nombre de
relations et de liens et dont certains
de ces liens pourront être utilisés
comme des ressources et au contraire des
individus
- intégrer par exemple des ouvriers avec
un réseau social moins étendue davantage
resserré autour de la sphère familiale
et amicale proches et pour parler de ça
on va notamment reprendre la typologie
des différents capitaux développé par
pierre bourdieu avant de vous les listes
et un petit rappel sur le fait que
pierre bourdieu a une vision
particulière de l'espace social
il a une vision de l'espace social comme
un espace de lutte tout le monde se bat
dans la société pour occuper une place
dominante dans le champ social et si
possible pour ne pas occuper une
position dominée et pour avoir une
position dominante
il faut posséder un certain nombre de
ressources ce sont ses ressources que
bourdieu appelle des capitaux ces
capitaux qu'il faut maximiser pour être
au sommet de l'échelle sociale ils sont
de trois types le capital économique le
capital culturel et le capital social
alors le capital economics et facile à
comprendre c'est juste le fait d'avoir
de la thune je vais pas m'étendre là
dessus alors le capital culturel je vais
essayer de passer vite mais je referai
définitivement un épisode là dessus pour
aller vite on peut simplement dire que
c'est l'ensemble des connaissances et
des compétences des individus et enfin
celui qui nous intéresse ici le capital
social c'est à dire l'ensemble des
relations mobilisables qui peuvent être
utilisées comme une ressource par
exemple mettons que vous essayez de
faire un stage dans une entreprise de
rempaillage de cornemuse et que votre
papa est justement un luthier reconnue
dans le monde de la cornemuse qui je ne
suppose ne doit pas être un champ social
particulièrement vaste
eh bien il ya de fortes chances pour que
votre papa connaissent justement une
entreprise qui a besoin d'un stagiaire
voir qu'ils puissent vous prendre
directement dans son atelier bon bah
typiquement là c'est l'exemple du
capital social utilisé comme ressource
trouver un stage est globalement si vous
possédez ces trois capitaux en grande
quantité un an gros date une de la
culture et des contacts vous avez de
grandes chances de faire partie des
dominants de notre société et il se
trouve que parfois l'un de ces capitaux
peut prendre le pas sur les autres quand
ils sont déséquilibrés par exemple si
l'université fait principalement croître
le capital culturel ce que propose de
cultiver les écoles de commerce c'est
principalement le capital social le plus
important dans ces écoles à au moins
5000 euros l'année c'est de se
constituer un carnet d'adressés qui
pourra nous être utile pour plus tard
vous avez intégré la meilleure business
coupe d'europe et vous avez le droit
d'être filmé cette histoire c'est une
occasion de dire qu avec tout le monde
ici tout faire un résultat
de la même façon il n'ya qu'à voir
comment les camarades de promo de l'ena
ont tendance à se recroiser par la suite
pour comprendre que la possession d'un
réseau social est tendu semble une
condition sinequanone de l'accession au
pouvoir dans nos sociétés par suite
c'est là que l'analyse sociologique des
réseaux sociaux devient intéressante car
c'est elle qui va nous permettre
d'identifier les relations de pouvoir et
d'influencé au sein de la population
bon mais j'en viens à la question qui
nous intéresse aujourd'hui est game of
thrones dans tout ça la question que se
posent les auteurs du papier qu'on
étudie aujourd'hui c'est qui c'est le
personnage principal dans game of
thrones en termes d'analysé de réseaux
ça signifie d'une part quel personnage
entretient le plus de relation et
d'autre part lequel des personnages à
une position dominante au sein de ce
réseau et ensuite comme on l'a vu un des
éléments constitutifs des positions de
pouvoir dans un réseau complet c'est
quel personnage occupe une position de
trous structurale c'est à dire de pont
entre des réseaux qui sans eau ne
communiquerait pas en listant tous les
personnages contenu dans le troisième
livre de la saga
les chercheurs ont donc modéliser un
graff qui représente cent sept
personnages reliés par 353 connexion
pour étudier l'importance des
personnages ils ont utilisé plusieurs
mesures pour essayer d'évaluer leur
degré de centralité le nombre de liens
le nombre de relations
le nombre de connexions avec des
personnages importants la distance
moyenne avec la relation et enfin le
temps d'apparition à l'écran
donc je vais pas vous faire poireauter
plus longtemps ce fameux graf le voici
alors la taille des noms sur ce
graphique indique l'importance des
personnages donc d'après l'analyse
mathématique
le grand gagnant du jeu des trônes ce
serait tyrion lannister on remarque que
c'est le personnage qui cumule le plus
grand temps d'écran qui est en lien avec
le plus grand nombre de personnages et
qui occupe la position la plus centrale
au sein de son réseau
on pourrait aussi ajouter le fait que
depuis la saison 7 il a également des
liens très forts avec dan harris ceux
qui le transforme de fait en trou
structurale donc il ya fort à parier que
sa position a dû encore se solidifier au
cours des dernières saisons
malgré son importance à
soc on remarque que dan harris manque
encore fortement de connexion sur le
continent de westeros
et c'est sûr que ce ne sont pas ses
relations avec ver gris jorat ou khal
drogo qui vont lui apporter beaucoup d'
influence dans le jeu des trônes oui en
particulier pour khal drogo ça va lui
être difficile d'avoir quelques
influences que ce soit maintenant ah
ouais donc y'a plus de respect qua non
seulement tu fais un épisode de game of
thrones sommes invités et en plus ces
seuils de m'humilier qua non même espace
que je parlé d'un truc de mathématiques
là je pensais pas que ça allait est
intéressé mais tu parle français toi
maintenant ils fassent maisi guéri mais
en étudiant d'un peu plus près ce graphe
on peut voir quand même apparaître un
certain nombre d'éléments déjà on peut
voir que robert baratheon même s'il est
finalement resté très peu à l'antenne a
quand même un degré de centralité
important bon après tout c'est normal
c'est quand même le roi mais justement
ce qu'on peut remarquer aussi c'est
qu'il était passablement isolé ne
partageant que des liens faibles et
assez peu nombreux alors même qu'il
était au centre de ce réseau et surtout
on remarque qu'il n'a pas de communauté
baratheon robert est de couleur bleu
donc complètement intégrée à la
communauté des lannister et pour le coup
les sept communautés qui apparaissent
ici en couleurs n'ont pas du tout été
décidé par les chercheurs
mais c'est l'algorithme qui les a fait
apparaître tout seul simplement à partir
des données de l'analyse des relations
pour pouvoir mieux lire et interpréter
ce graphe
il va quand même falloir rentrer un peu
dans la cuisine algorithmique et
regarder comment ont été mesurés les
différentes degré de centralité pris en
compte dans ce calcul
ce graphique résume donc les résultats
des six façons différentes de mesurer la
centralité des personnages et qui
apportent chacune une dimension
différente à l'analyse la taille des
bars indique le score mesuré et le
numéro indique le classement des
personnages selon cette mesure
on remarque ici que pour la première
mesure qui indique simplement le nombre
de connexions avec d'autres personnages
thirion a clairement le nombre le plus
élevé de connexions c'est qui le place
clairement première place devant tous
les autres protagonistes
le white naissent des grilles représente
le nombre
deux relations avec des personnages sans
qu'il y ait nécessairement de connexion
directe mais il n'est pas surprenant que
les personnages ayant le plus grand
nombre de connexions sont aussi ceux qui
ont le plus grand nombre de relations
ce qui explique la relative similarités
entre les deux résultats
le lte facteurs représentent en gros le
même indicateur que le précédent mais
cette fois avec une boucle de
rétroaction
en gros c est ce que mes relations me
relie à des joueurs influents ce qui
pourra donc avoir un avantage pour ma
propre influence
c'est là que robert baratheon par
exemple connaît un gros boost entre les
deux mesures parce qu'ils passent de la
14e place à la neuvième place entre le
nombre de relations simples et le nombre
de relations avec rétroaction en effet
le roi n'a que dix-huit connexion mais
la moitié d'entre elles le sont avec
d'autres participants importants du jeu
des trônes la plupart des dirigeants
bénéficient de cette boucle rétroactive
et c'est moins le cas des personnages
plus isolé comme john brown ou d'amneris
qui perdent un certain nombre de places
ensuite via l'outil pagerank qui est en
fait l'outil mathématique utilisée par
google pour mesurer qualitativement la
popularité d'une page web et qui influe
donc sur l'ordre d'apparition des
recherches dans google
ici ce qu'il faut comprendre c'est que
chaque personnage a une importance
propre mais que cette importance peut
être augmentée par l'importance de ses
voisins pour le calcul on considère
simplement que chaque personnage une
importance donnée et qu'il passe une
fraction de cette importance à chacun de
ses voisins cette fraction pouvant
changer en fonction du poids du voisin
on remarque que la mesure du pèlerin qui
est en fait assez similaire aux reds
lecteurs si ce n'est pour d'amneris qui
saute directement de la 14e à la
cinquième place donc l'outil pagerank
arrive bien à identifier le charisme de
daenerys qui récupère pratiquement toute
l'importance des personnes qui
l'entourent ce qui la place comme une
joueuse importante malgré son petit
nombre de connexions cela nous amène à
la cinquième mesure la cloche ne sonne
quality qui identifie la distance
moyenne entre un personnage et un autre
à linverse d autres mesures ici c'est
d'avoir une petite barre qui préjuge de
la centralité du personnage on remarque
que toutes les mesures sont assez
proches en fait un les unes des autres
sauf pour dan ellis évidemment inquiets
la plus éloignée
et on remarque alors que sansa et irion
semble quand même être les personnages
qui entretiennent le plus de relation de
proximité pour finir la dernière mesure
et la plus subtile de tout et elle
repose sur les théories d'accès aux
ressources qu'on a vu avec les six
degrés de séparation la between us and
quality mesure la capacité d'un
personnage à interagir avec un autre en
utilisant des chemins très court on
comprend facilement pourquoi d'amneris
et robert ont des scores élevés du fait
de leur position dominante qui les fait
interagir directement avec les
protagonistes importants autour d'eux on
remarque cela dit que c'est la seule
mesure pour laquelle thirion n'est pas
premier même s'il est bien placé 1 sans
doute en raison de son rôle de main du
roi mais il est notable que c'est john
snow qui arrive en première place ici et
cela n'est pas particulièrement étonnant
en effet la vitrine des centrales qui
permet de mesurer le fait d'avoir une
position stratégique au sein du réseau
et avoir une position stratégique pour
un personnage
ça signifie que pour qu'une information
passe d'une partie du réseau à l'autre
il faille nécessairement qu'elle passe
par ce personnage est la position de
john à ce propos est particulièrement
intéressante on voit la taille de son
donc c'est effectivement un acteur
important du jeu des trônes et cette
fois ci sa place est importante
justement parce qu'il joue le rôle de
trous structurale entre d'un côté la
garde de nuit
de l'autre les différents lord et les
différentes maisons et enfin les
sauvageons de l'autre côté du mur
ce qu'ils ont fait effectivement le
meilleur personnage possible pour donner
l'alerté
holmes
[Musique]
connectez votre problème et on est
maintenant qu il entretient des
relations à la fois formelles et
informelles avec la mère des dragons il
y à fort à parier qu'elle sera tiré
profit de la taille et de la position de
son réseau pour conclure cette analyse
des réseaux dans game of thrones est
particulièrement intéressante et elle
remplit parfaitement le rôle de ce type
d'analysé en sociologie elle permet
d'avoir une meilleure compréhension de
comment se structure un jeu de
domination au sein d'un champ social
données en particulier ici même si le
roi robert est en relation avec des
personnages influents une interagit en
fait qu'avec un très petit nombre de
joueurs ce qui fragilise
considérablement sa position à
l'intérieur du réseau tandis que des
personnages moins élevés
hiérarchiquement comme c'est le cas de
tyrion peuvent avoir un capital social
très élevé ce qui augmente mécaniquement
le nombre de ressources auxquelles il
peut avoir accès oui oui il peut accéder
à des ressources 1 mais oui un une
petite critique néanmoins parce que
cette étude souffre en fait d exact
mêmes limites auxquelles sont confrontés
les sociologues qui essayent de retracer
les relations sociales d'une communauté
c'est qu'il est impossible d'avoir une
connaissance parfaite de l'ensemble des
relations dans un espace donné
et il faut donc utiliser des outils
chargés de les faire apparaître ces
outils peuvent être variés ça peut être
de l'observation des entretiens
directement avec les individus ou même
de nouveaux outils 1 basé sur les
nouvelles technologies
mais de fait aucun de ces outils de
collecte d'information n'est infaillible
ici le moyen de collecter l'information
c'est la lecture du troisième livre de
la saga et du coup ce qui représentait
c'est pas le véritable réseau qui existe
game of thrones mais c'est le réseau
dont a connaissance le lecteur et ça
fait une grosse différence
en effet un personnage est très
étrangement peu important dans cette
analyse
et il s'agit du personnage de varices
qui semble ne partage et que peu de
connexions
encore moins que gregor clegane ses
dires est la raison pour laquelle
varices est tellement bas dans le
classement bas c'est parce que c'est un
espion donc sont raisonnés
pas connus par les lecteurs et a
fortiori pas par les chercheurs
mais je vous rappelle que le surnom de
varices c'est la renier il est au sommet
d'un vaste réseau d'information qui lui
permettent d'être au courant de tout ce
qui se passe dans l'ouest hérault ce il
a même été à deux doigts de réussir à
faire assassiner d'amneris à des
kilomètres de distance de la saison 1
ce qui laisse présager de la force de
son réseau donc il ya fort à parier que
si on arrivait à mettre au jour la
totalité du réseau du maître des
chuchotements il arriverait beaucoup
plus haut dans le classement
cet épisode est maintenant terminée
j'espère qu'il vous a plu qui vous a
permis d'en savoir un peu plus sur
l'analyse de réseaux s'il vous a plu
n'hésitez pas à mettre un pouce vers le
haut à vous abonner à partager la vidéo
si jamais vous avez encore faim et vous
voulez en savoir encore plus sur
l'analyse de réseaux en sociologie
je vous enjoins très fortement aller
voir une conférence de claire bidart que
je mets en descriptions dans la vidéo
pour le coup ça a été une des grosses
bases de travail pour moi pour faire
cette vidéo et je lui ai piqué la moitié
de ces slides donc il n'est que justice
que je vous enjoignant très fortement
allez l'avoir lavée de la conférence
fait deux heures trente mais elle est
extrêmement explicite extrêmement claire
tribus très accessible pour tout le
monde donc si jamais le sujet vous a
intéressé je vous enjoins très fortement
à aller la visionner quant à moi je vous
dis eh bien à la prochaine
des bisous prenez soin de vous ciao
[Musique]
h